the jurogan experience in a young
life you have accomplished incredible
things
like for people that don't know you won
the olympic gold medalist at
17 and then you won it again four years
later
yep the only american boxer ever
i think like only another like no
boxer's ever done that right
in america no not from america just me
and uh i mean you've gone
multiple weight classes and now you're
considering fighting an mma
i mean you you kind of cleared out
boxing in a lot of ways
it's always something more to be
accomplished
in boxing but i'm venturing off into mma
because i really want to see
am i as great as i think i am and i
think i
am so i'm excited to be fighting with
the pfl later on this year
and just um taking it from there and
seeing what happens
well i think when someone is as good as
you are at boxing
you could basically do anything you want
in life you just have to put the same
amount of focus that you put on boxing
to whatever it is that you apply
yourself to
yeah those rare human beings that can do
what you've been able to do it's a rare
person
five p's proper preparation prevents
poor performance there you go
so in mma i'm not coming over like hey
i'm in boxing i'm boxing all you girls
up
it's like i'm at jackson wayne jim you
know with coach jackson
i listen i've seen you kick the bag i've
seen you throw kicks
i was very impressed i can't believe
you're already that good
it's real i was like well maybe she put
you were throwing high kicks
yeah i don't know how they can go up
that high today showing me the technique
up and i was like
whoa this is insane do you stretch
all the time are you a person who like
when you were boxing i mean i know
most athletes stretch but having a full
split is not
really it's not really required to punch
people
but you obviously have very flexible
legs i've been doing yoga
for the past few months so i was able to
kick high when i first
went to jackson wing gym in december i
was able to kick high
but not for very long i probably would
get two or three good high kicks and i'm
like yo let's bring it down a level
now from all the stretching when they
got that pad up there and they like kick
it
i just do the form and my leg can go up
there over and over and over again just
from the stretching and actually
being a bit more flexible than what i
was before so i stretch but i stretch
more serious now
what brought you into yoga um really
it was the mma fans to be honest they're
like you're gonna have to stretch and
you know people are on there you know
talking
trash or whatever trolls but they were
saying like i read a lot of comments and
i'm like
they're like you know she's gonna have a
problem with kicking she's not flexible
her legs are big blah blah
so i would read some of that stuff and
do my own research and i'm like damn
they're right
so my goal for one of my new year's
resolutions was
to be able to do the splits by the end
of the year so
i have a yoga teacher um and me and her
go
like up on up on zoom twice a week and
she's like having me do these stretches
and i'm like girl you is something else
her name is sekina have you done hot
yoga ever
no not yet i heard it's brutal though
it's more rudimental
it is brutal for sure but one good thing
about it is when you get that hot and
sweaty
your muscles become really pliable and
you can make really good gains that way
like in terms of flexibility
oh wow maybe should maybe i should try
it with zucchini yeah i always find that
i'm way more flexible
in uh hot yoga class than i am anywhere
else you can do the splits yeah i could
do a splits
damn yeah ahead of me i'm
old i started when i was 15. you know so
you still do the splits your body is
like
jacked up you should not be able to do
this blitz
there's a guy who fights for one fc that
makes me look like a twig
his name is elaine ngali he's okay he's
super
jacked and he's one of the most flexible
guys i've ever seen in my life
oh insanely flexible but flexible
everywhere his spine is flexible
he can he can bend over backwards
standing and touch the back of his
like is touch his palms to the ground
and then flip his feet over the top
his instagram is incredible because he's
built like a superhero
see if he find his uh his instagram he's
built like a super i mean like a freak
of nature that's
incredibly flexible wow
he just puts a lot of time and
dedication to flexibility
you can't it can be done it's just there
he is look at him
i mean come on and when you see this guy
when you see this guy move and you see
him fight
i mean do the video one so you could see
him oh no no go that one right there
with the dude with the blue shorts right
in front where
he head kicks his dude watch this guy i
mean you see
his his flexibility is incredible but
that's one thing about the kicks though
you really have to condition those shins
for that oh yeah
remember when i first started i was like
probably like five kicks in i'm like
yeah
just the back right yeah just the bag
itself then when we went up to the pads
i'm like coach
he got softer pads serious he's like
champ these are my softest ones i'm like
it takes a while
it takes a while you see some people
they start whacking their shins with
like
coke bottles and stuff like that just
trying to toughen them up yeah they do
all kinds of things
i can kick really hard now oh there you
are look at this
seriously superman punches everything
head kicks
the thing is some of this stuff i
learned i learned superman punch that
same day
so when he showed me at one time we just
started doing it and he was like you're
doing good like i can look at it now and
tell you my mistakes
right now but i'm not gonna say too much
because i fixed them already
but sometime when i threw like the head
kicks my kicks would
my my hands would go down at the same
time how did you get to
jackson winkle john because first of all
you couldn't have picked a better gym
to to train at the one of the best gyms
in the world but what what brought you
there
um actually i've always had like
i i believe in technique and training
people may look at me boxing about oh
she's just naturally fast she's
naturally strong he's like no
i am strategically smart in boxing and i
have a lot of skill
i may look like i'm a beast out there
but it takes a lot of skill to land
those punches
body work defense which is i probably
got hit three times my last fight
well you went one of your fights what
was that woman from
oh god what was her name was your first
world title fight
she was a blonde lady nikki adler yeah
she went a whole round without landing a
single punch on you yeah
and i i ended that fight in the fifth
round yeah you
anybody that doesn't think that you have
technique just doesn't understand boxing
yeah they're they're just like oh she's
a one man you can't respond to those
people you can't yeah they're weird no
you
clearly have superior technique
i agree no so for mma i was just like i
already had signed a contract with the
pfl
and now i'm like okay how what do you
have to do for the five ps to play
in effect and i was like i need to get
the best trainer and i just remember
like in 2016
me and johnny bones we were talking at
the espys and he was like yo
you be the perfect boxer to come over to
mma and i was like
it's true because you're really young
you're 25 now
yeah i turned 26 in two days oh boy yeah
super yeah well an early happy birthday
to you
thank you so that's a perfect age
because you're you still
are capable of getting elite at all the
arts you're still
you could get a lead at brazilian jiu
jitsu you can get elite at striking
with kicking and muay thai you can you
mean you're young enough that you could
do all that [ __ ]
yeah i think it's just all about like
one having the right teachers
and also getting in there and doing it
but i mean having a
having a body to do it like i'm glad
that i didn't wait till i was like 35
you know 36 because then i would just be
starting
it'll set me back and it'd be like i'm
going in here starting new and my body
isn't even
in his prime like right now i don't
think that my body has
has peaked yet like where i've been as
strong as i can be as fast as i can be i
still think like
i'm like right there i just haven't i
haven't touched where i'm like okay this
is the best my body can be at i haven't
i haven't touched that yet
they think a pro athlete your prime is
somewhere between 28 and 32 i think they
said because that's when your body
lines up with your brain i was hoping it
was 26. maybe it is 26.
i was hoping tyson won the world title
at 20.
you know yeah right it's like jon jones
won the world title at 22.
it's like you can or he's 23 does john
jones 22 or 23.
he's the youngest ever ufc feel like he
was 21.
no no he wasn't 21. he was either 22 or
23
because 23. okay because before that i
think it was
josh barnett and he won the heavyweight
title i think it was 24.
you know but there's it's
you know it's it's different for
everybody like some people peak young
some people they as they get older they
get smarter
so they understand their body better and
so maybe their body doesn't quite work
as well as it did when they were 24 but
they're a better athlete
at 30 or 32 just because they know what
to do and how to do it better they
understand they have a
better communication with their body but
that's like
what you're doing by doing yoga and even
by expanding into martial arts that's
the key
it's like keeping your body doing
different things
and then you understand your body more
the more different stuff you do with it
so when did you start training in mma
december just december
and how often are you doing it um i was
at jackson wing gym
three weeks at a time so i'll be there
three weeks go home a week come back
three weeks go home a week come back
three weeks
um i was doing that because i really
just i like to just have my time when
i'm at home my family my boyfriend
i don't like just training training and
training training like should i drive
you crazy
so i'm like i gotta leave so now uh
starting back
and after my birthday in april i'll be
up in jackson wink for three weeks but i
only go home
weekend so i'll be there three weeks
then go home for friday saturday sunday
fly back sunday be there three weeks
again until
i have my actual fight so is the plan to
continue boxing as well
as fighting in mma yeah the overall goal
for me is to be
champion in boxing and be a champion mma
at the same time
once that's done then i don't know what
else i could possibly do like that'll be
like the end game for me
like that's it yeah so i know i can be
championing boxing which is
very easy to do because i'm already
accomplished so much in boxing
and the girls just can't [ __ ] with me in
boxing let's keep it real but
mma
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience